letting you know right out the gate this
video is brought to you by private
internet access going to talk about that
a little later but first Denzel's back
baby
[Music]
so The Equalizer 3 is the third chapter
and Antoine fuqua's equalizer Trilogy
starring Denzel said to be the final
chapter as well but they're all the
Final Chapter until they're not for
equalizer three Denzel's character is
settled down in this nice little town in
Italy I mean by settle down I mean he
was wounded and he's been patched up
he's been healing in this town and it's
an amazing place too nice people
gorgeous scenery delicious food the kind
of place where if you go to vacation
there you seriously consider just
forgetting to come back but of course
Underneath It All there are these
organized crime scumbags terrorizing the
citizens there luckily this is an
equalizer movie which means these simple
rules apply the more you [__] around
the more you're going to find out now
first of all Denzel carries this movie
he's essentially carried the entire
Trilogy the man is a consummate
professional I can't say anything new
that hasn't already been said about
Denzel over the decades you show me a
Denzel role in which he just phones it
in I will show you a movie you
apparently slept through complete and
total goat and he carries this film as
well he's intense he's deliberate you
know what I love about his character in
these movies is he all but begs the
baddies to just not [__] around let's
not find out today just go away please
you really feel it in equalizer three
you really feel like he wants to enjoy
the retirement that he's just fallen
into you feel that sense of community
and in a way in equalizer 3 you've never
seen before you feel that his characters
found some sort of joy happiness and
even peace now we will say this movie is
more of a slow burn than I thought it
was going to be maybe more of a slow
burn than some people want it to be
starts out with an action sequence holds
you over and appreciative on that
because it is a nice satisfying bloody
one but after that it takes about an
hour to really get things going in the
meantime you're hanging out with Denzel
in this town as he's getting to know the
people you see the organized crime
scumbag elements start to rear its ugly
head they start to cause problems
there's definitely a trajectory into
conflict that is coming but for that
first hour it really is seeing Denzel
get attached to the townspeople funny
enough I I can't remember any of the
characters names but you kind of don't
have to in order to feel these sense of
community I'm like hey you got the
doctor guy the cop guy the nice lady at
the cafe that might be a me thing I'm
[__] with names anyway suppose the point
is it is impressive that you don't need
to know their names in order to feel the
sense of community to feel the need for
this world these people this way of life
to be protected from [__] point
being it being a slow burn it was
burning with purpose Antoine fuke while
used that first half of the film to get
you attached to the community though not
so much the individual one that stands
out is Dakota Fanning in the film it
does feel like she's the film's day one
DLC like they had the movie and they
were like oh we need some American CIA
element in here okay here she is there
is a full circle thing that ends up
happening by the end but I feel like
her character in the film just ended up
padding the run time this movie does
feel a bit too long looking for Corners
to shave to make the run time shorter
that whole Arc would be it love the
banter too I don't know the banter is
the word but there is some Snappy
dialogue and comebacks in this film are
you warning me I'm preparing you ever
have a heated discussion debate argument
otherwise a verbal altercation then when
you're driving home and it's long over
you think of what you should have said
you're like ah
wish I'd said that he never has that
problem he says the optimum thing to say
in the moment it's a superpower that is
every bit as entertaining to watch as
the action is and I will say the big bad
egg is a lot of the guys you're dealing
with are the street level [__] but
the big Baddie the guy in charge of it
all I felt it came into the scene far
too late in the film I mean largely
throughout the film when you've been
dealing with these street level villains
who've been terrorizing this community
and you've been dealing with them as the
villains of the film to bring in the guy
behind it all just for the last act felt
wasteful but in the end I enjoyed myself
equalizer 3 isn't John Wick it's easy to
compare equalizer to John Wick maybe at
a it's like Sega Genesis and Super
Nintendo similar at a glance but in
reality so different it's not a balls to
the wall from beginning to end action
sequence on the edge of your seat type
action film much more of a slow burn for
the first half but like I said that
first half is used very well and I have
myself a good time no alcohol required
and once again letting you know this
video is brought to you by private
internet access the VPN service which
hides your IP address Shields your
online life from the ever-prying eyes
and the spies of the internet whether
it's public Wi-Fi your Wi-Fi your data
is always at risk of being stolen it's
the world we live in because let's just
be real in this world there are people
who suck and as you Traverse this
digital hellscape those people want the
sweet nectar known as your digital
information we lock up the doors to our
houses and our cars we already know the
value of being safe protecting our
personal information should be no
different and from our entertainment fun
factor in a world where some websites
and streaming services will region lock
their content private internet access
allows you to change your IP address
among 80 countries enjoy your Unshackled
streaming experience and now you can use
one subscription to protect an unlimited
amount of devices so use the link in the
description to get an 83 discount on
private internet access that's just two
dollars and three cents per month plus
they're giving you four extra months for
free make sure to use my link in the
description that's the best deal on
private internet access all right so the
equalizer three have you seen it what
did you think about it or equalizer is a
Trilogy now so hey what can rank them
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]